明日は雨なんかな頭に出せ切るはじめ返事ずっとば大丈夫
大雨降る前日に頭いったけどあるけど片頭痛で躾を出したメーカー
お兄ちゃんということです珍しくちょっと話しますね色々ユーロつってもまあ内容は
漫画なことなんですけどもあの国そもそもあんまり漫画って言わない派の人間なんです
よどっちかって言われるとアニメの方が見るんですよ僕だって100ジャンこうやって
画面だけ見てたら勝手に進んでくし声でもわかるし
何か別にしなきゃいけないことがあってもなんかこうしながらでも見れるの
アニメだと思ってるんで基本的に僕が2名を見るんですけども平均ちょっとですね漫画
にはまってしまいましてコソコソと色んな漫画を買っております肇社長ですスマホで
漫画たっぷりとかで結構ゆんですけども実際に家具ってなるとそれなりに好きなもの
しか買わないなっていうことでちょっと今日は僕が最近読んでる漫画の紹介をしようと
思います
[音楽]
シンプルや7 c プロなんですけどみんな逆に考えてください僕そうそうアナンダに
ついて語ることないですから僕の趣味というかそういう中どんな孫読んでるんだろう
っていうのは面白そうだなって思ってなんか読んでくれると嬉しいなぐらいの感じで
ちょっと
何個ご紹介させていただきます
ってないかっ何これいうでそんなめっちゃ読んでるわけじゃないですよ全然なんか
色んな漫画詳しいわけでもないんでとりあえず僕が読んでみては50買ったなくてもね
ちょっと紹介していこうと思います
a まずはこちらです聲の形これはもうなんかすごかったですね
映画化も晴れていって話の内容としてはあの
耳が聞こえない女の子の話なんですよ
映画見てすごい面白そうだなと思って何かもっと深く見てみたいなとって万能買った
わけなんですけどなかなか考えさせられます
小学校の時ってこんなんか
ひどいいじめ悪意はすごいあるわけじゃないんですけども知らぬ間に行っちゃ酷い
イジメみたいなやつがすごい生々しく書かれてあの見ててすごい心が痛くなりましただ
が主人公はなんか見てそれが悪いことだと思ってないっていうわけではないんですけど
正しいことだってどこかで思いながらそれをやっちゃってて
小学校の時に耳が聞こえない女の子にとんでもないよ
いじめをしていた主人公が高校になってその言葉たあって当時のことをどう思ったか
男の子がどう思ってたか女かと思ってたかとかみたいな感じでちょっとお話がと動いて
いくかっていうところがあるんですけど
耳の聞こえない白いなのこの翔子ちゃんが
とっても可愛いです知子ちゃんマジ可愛いですよ好きこれは面白いというか話が気に
なるというか重い重い
漫画ですね中旬結構くらいに出るんだよんですごい夢中になれる漫画でした
孫がこの漫画を通して何を一番言いたかっていうと祥子ちゃん好きこれではこちら食料
全類これですねあのアプリの漫画で見つけて1巻だけ読むとめちゃくちゃ面白いという
か何かと
塩害が気になる最近の漫画でよくあるんですけどチュチュ詠唱ものすごくしてどうなる
んだろうって勇気身なりがハンパなさすぎてアプリのバッグを超えて実物を買って
しまったっていうやつなんですけどこれはまた面白いと言うか設定が面白いですね
まぁこの手の漫画坊結構尽きるんですけどなんかね地球温暖化がめちゃくちゃ数が
ちょっと未来の話で主人公が高校生で
突然に帰宅中に拉致されるんですよで拉致された先がなんかよくわかんない場所でこれ
なんか米朝された人間やなんかすごい太っちゃった人間の姿よくわかんないことが
たくさんあったんですけどもその理由がこの中に書いてあるコミュニティ後ろに書いて
あるんですよございました
わーいまあとりあえずでちゃんとその地球温暖化になったのも理由があっててなんで
そんな冷凍人間とか太らされた右がいるかというともうタイトルの通り
食料人間というわけなんですけどまぁ何か絡んでるなっていうのがわかっていくお話で
ございます設定が子じゃないですよねまず人間が冷凍されてる時点でもあそ爆笑する
ことじゃねーのは大変ですよ
人間でレートされちゃダメですかメイドされた人間がのすごいデブにされたりしてて
インパクトがすごくてちょっとハマっちゃった感じ
です
これミス大丈夫だいいよねぇ
はいこちら2末のハーレムでございます5巻まではもう表せがうーんまあ一言で言い
ましょうエロ漫画ですこれは真似を設定だけの男の子だったらたなんっていうかこれ
大丈夫なのかどうかの設定だけの話をさせていただけますと主人公が病気にかかって
しまいましてその病気を治すためにこのちょっとまた未来の話なんですけども
のコールドスリープ主人公だけで通して何年後かに復活するとその病気が治ってるよっ
ていう曲にかかっちゃって5年ほどちょっとコールドスリープで主人公だけ時間が
止まってた主人公が5年後に起きるとなんと
世界中の男性が全部中古車
これ何を意味するかと言いますと数字子が大きな瞬間世界は女の子しかいない状態に
なってるんですよというわけで週末の晴れ打ってタイトルなんですけど
エラーやまさにハール分どこ見ても女の子ですし
男がいなくなった世界ってまたちょっとヤバいじゃないですか子供も売れないから前例
が滅亡の道をたどるしかないけどやっぱそれだとさ
それだとやっ白い紙ツボスターじゃないですかじゃあどうするか
そうでしょ男性から男性が読んでると思う
[音楽]
ってなっちゃうと思います僕の回り方もみんなこれ様から最高って書いていますはい
ラストですこれあの島で僕評価へ呼んでて2中を割ってしまいました惚れねなぜをも
それと思うんだけど神楽実は小倉せたいこれは家具やたんですねあーまあ僕国この場
から何を進めるかといいますと
m 普通に可愛いんですけども内容がまずであのクソお揃いでしたまた
ちょっと本屋さん行く機会があって何か書いてあるかずりんだよな
天才たちの恋愛つ動線という男どんなノベルですけどめっちゃ頭いいんですよぷっ天才
の2人がペットも察してるんですよねピタリと思うぞお互いがお互いを吸ってみたいな
あっ
好きななぁけど俺はまあ好きだけどねあじゃああー私のこと好きなのですねー
付き合ってやらんこともないですけれども
みたいな開けがそのプライドの高い2人が自分から告白なんてするわけねーぞ国家がし
たら負けだぞっとなんと戦略と上に立ちたいっていう気持ちがあって男の子と女の子が
どっちが先に来書かせるかっていうそのすごい頭脳戦が繰り広げられている
まずでもすごいラブコメっぽく見えるんですけどもすごいなんか
かゆみしすぎてて滅茶苦茶面白かった夜戦普通に今日声だして一に手錠笑ってました
今からちょっと誤解をんですけど多分笑います見てください
漫画で声出してもらったら本当に面白いってことだと思うんでみます
ん
やますねふたりともっとね人々も絶対に自分から行かないんですよ
1分
これまずい漫画ですよ
割とここ最近で一番ちょっときてるなんだこの前燃やしたハンズは2人にくっついて
ほしい
どうすんだよなえないじゃんそれだとああああわあ
じゃないじゃないぞんにょねそれです
[音楽]
やっぱり女ないん
五感がとてもいい話でしたふざけ1234まで超面白かったりなんで4巻からこんな
泣かせに行くんだよ
う
うううう
はぁっ
ね患いマジで合わせないと彼はという感じで1番がにはまっております
[音楽]
ジャンヌ
me
あっはぁ